Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Wir machen heute etwas ganz Klassisches
und es ist unglaublich, dass ich in den letzten 5 Jahren noch kein Spargelrezept für meinen Kanal abgefilmt habe.
Dabei ist es so einfach und so lecker!
Ich mache heute ganz klassische Spargeln mit Sauce Hollandaise und mit Kartoffeln aus dem Backofen.
Und vom Zeitmanagement her würde man erstmal mit den Kartoffeln anfangen, denn die brauchen am längsten.
Alles andere geht super schnell.
Ich habe jetzt hier sehr, sehr kleine Kartoffeln. Das sind Bio Kartoffeln, ich werde die Schale mitverwenden
und werde sie jetzt zuallererst mit meinem Wellenschneider entweder halbieren wenn sie klein sind
oder wenn sie ein bisschen größer sind, dann werde ich sie auch dritteln.
Und das mache ich jetzt, ich habe sie natürlich vorher schon gewaschen.
Und ich schreibe euch alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung.
[Hamza] Hey, du sollst mich fragen!
[Kiki] Achso!
[Kiki] Und alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen unten in der..?
[Hamza] Infobox!
[Kiki] Infobox!
So, jetzt nehme ich mir mein Backblech.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch eine Auflaufform nehmen, ich nehme immer gern mein Backblech.
Ich gebe die Kartoffeln direkt da rein. Und das ist heute von den Portionen her würde ich sagen für 2 gute Esser.
Also 2 gute Esser oder 3 Personen, die so weniger essen.
So, dann nehme ich mir Olivenöl.
Nehmt gutes Olivenöl! Kaltgepresst, nativ extra.. Natürlich werde ich euch meins in die Infobox verlinken.
Und da gebe ich jetzt auch ordentlich von drauf.
Und an Gewürzen habe ich mir überlegt neben Salz und Pfeffer - das mache ich jetzt direkt -
Neben Salz und Pfeffer nehme ich heute noch Rosmarin, dann werden das richtig leckere Rosmarinkartoffeln.
Und ich finde das passt dann auch geschmacklich auch richtig gut zu dem Spargel und zur Sauce Hollandaise.
Aber den Rosmarin jetzt nicht so als ganze Stängel dazugeben
sondern nochmal minimal fein hacken.
Also erstmal hier vom Stängel runterziehen und dann hacke ich das nochmal und gebe das drauf.
Oah, das riecht... oah, das riecht richtig gut, Leute! Komm, riech mal!
[Hamza] Sind das Drogen oder was? *lacht*
[Kiki] Oah!
[Hamza] Keine Macht den Drogen! Boah, das riecht echt gut.
[Kiki] Das riecht heftig, ne?
[Hamza] Das riecht nach Medizin!
[Kiki] Nach Medizin, ja!
[Hamza] Aber so leckere Medizin!
[Kiki] Ja, ich habe jetzt nichts Negatives damit assoziiert irgendwie.
Und wenn ihr den Rosmarin dazugegeben habt, dann einfach nur noch mit den Händen schön durchmengen
und dann kommen die Kartoffeln in den Backofen.
Der muss schön vorgeheizt sein. Der muss richtig heiß sein, 200° C Ober- und Oberhitze.
Je nach Größe brauchen sie 25-30min, ich würd' sagen bei mir werden's 30min.
So, wir nutzen jetzt die Zwischenzeit.
Während die Kartoffeln im Ofen garen, machen wir jetzt die Sauce Hollandaise.
Tut mir mal bitte einen Gefallen: Immer wenn ich irgendwas mit Soße mache, Soße..
Dann bekomme ich immer Kommentare, dass ich's falsch ausspreche.
[Kiki] Heißt es jetzt "Sose"? "Soße"?
[Hamza] Sause!
Also Sauce Hollandaise ist klar, bei dem Begriff weiß man`s
aber so allgemein, ganz allgemein! Schreibt's mal bitte in die Kommentare.
Also ich mache jetzt folgendes: Ich gebe jetzt in meine Pfanne
- Ihr könnt auch einen kleinen Topf nehmen -
Wasser, Pfefferkörner, außerdem noch eine grob gehackte Zwiebel.
Da könntet ihr jetzt auch z.B. 'ne Schalotte nehmen, je nachdem, was ihr da habt.
So, ein Lorbeerblatt und Apfelessig.
Also weißen Essig, ich nehme gerne Apfelessig.
Und warum machen wir das Ganze? Wir wollen den Geschmack von diesen ganzen Zutaten
aber wir wollen nicht generell die ganzen groben Stücke.
Und selbst wenn ich jetzt die Zwiebel pürieren würde, das macht nichts mit unserer Konsistenz.
Die Konsistenz von Sauce Hollandaise ist ja so richtig weich, sämig,  so richtig zart einfach.
Wie Seide im Gaumen!
Wir wollen nur den Geschmack aber nicht die Konsistenz von diesen Zutaten. Und daher machen wir das vorher so,
dass wir diese ganzen Zutaten jetzt einmal miteinander aufkochen lassen und ein bisschen einreduzieren lassen.
Das dauert jetzt ein paar Minuten, grob geschätzt 5-6min und dann machen wir auch schon weiter.
Von dem Sud bleibt nur ein kleines bisschen übrig
aber das kleine bisschen macht schon viel im Geschmack aus, das brauche ich aber gleich erst wieder.
Ich habe in der Zwischenzeit auch schon mal Butter geschmolzen.
Die ist jetzt richtig schön warm, ich fülle sie mir aber um
weil gleich kommt die in einem dünnen Strahl zum Ei.
Aber es ist immer einfacher, wenn ich mir das einmal umfülle mit so 'ner kleinen Öffnung vorne dran,
dann kann ich's nämlich kontrollierter gleich mit zum Eigelb geben.
So, und jetzt kommen wir zu den Eiern. Also Sauce Hollandaise wird ja mit frischen Eiern gemacht.
Ich habe hier ganz frische Bio Eier, macht euch da wegen Salmonellen etc. keine Sorgen
wenn euer Ei ganz frisch ist. Es sei denn, ihr seid schwanger, dann solltet ihr natürlich darauf verzichten.
Ich werde das jetzt einmal trennen und gebe dann meine Eigelbe einmal in die Schüssel
und mein Eiweiß brauche ich für dieses Rezept nicht aber ich hab da gaaanz viele Ideen.
Entweder schlage ich mir das mit ein bisschen Erythrit auf, das mag ich so als Snack.
Oder ich geb's mir morgen einfach mit in mein Frühstücksei.
Und man könnte das jetzt auch im Kühlschrank aufbewahren für 24h
und daraus lassen sich dann gut Macarons machen.
Ich müsste übrigens mein Macarons Rezept mal wieder neu abfilmen.
Das Rezept ist nämlich genial, ich habe viel dafür getüftelt aber das Video ist schon sehr alt.
Ich wasche mir jetzt mal eben die Hände.
Und zum Eigelb gebe ich jetzt noch einen Spritzer Zitronensaft.
Und als nächstes nehme ich mir einfach meinen Pürierstab und fange an,
das Ganze einmal zu pürieren bis es ein bisschen dicker wird.
So, jetzt ist es schön schaumig und ein bisschen dicker und an der Stelle jetzt
in einem ganz feinen, dünnen Strahl die Butter mit dazugeben.
Und dann werdet ihr merken, dass es nochmal einen Ticken dicker wird.
Das liegt daran, dass sich im Eigelb Emulgatoren befinden.
Die bewirken quasi, dass sobald die Butter mit drin ist,
das Ganze so eine richtig schöne, sämige Konsistenz bekommt.
Weltklasse! Weltklasse, ich find's geil!
Ich finde diese Konsistenz sieht jetzt schon soo sämig und so cremig aus!
Jetzt kommt hier noch das Zwiebelsud mit rein.
Einmal kurz noch mit dazugeben und nochmal pürieren.
Und das Einzige, das jetzt noch fehlt, ist natürlich Salz.
Das gebe ich ganz zum Schluss mit dazu zum Abschmecken.
Und die Konsistenz! Ich sag's euch, es gibt nichts Geileres
- Ich sag's, wie's ist! - als selbstgemachte Sauce Hollandaise.
Und vor allem ging's auch schnell.
[Hamza] Ach das ist jetzt Sauce Hollandaise?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Achso, ich hab's nicht verstanden. Voll vercheckt!
Das ist die fertige Sauce Hollandaise, genau.
Wie gesagt: Noch Salz mit rein, abschmecken.
Und ich schreibe euch wie immer die ganze genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Dann könnt ihr euch das direkt screenshotten und einkaufen gehen.
Wobei: Für die Sauce Hollandaise habe ich eigentlich immer alle Zutaten Zuhause.
Einmal probieren..
Ja.. boah, diese Cremigkeit!
Ein bisschen Salz noch..
Die Kartoffeln sind auch gleich fertig, die kommen gleich aus dem Ofen.
Meine Sauce Hollandaise lege ich zur seite, bzw. ich habe auch noch einen Tipp für euch:
Ihr könnt sie auch einfach über einem Wasserbad stehen lassen damit sie auch schön warm bleibt.
Ich glaub das mache ich jetzt auch damit wir gleich alles schön warm essen, ne Hamza?
[Hamza] M-hm!
Und dann zeige ich euch, wie ihr Spargel am besten zubereitet.
Ich habe jetzt hier frischen, regionalen Bio Spargel.
Und ich werd das jetzt so machen, dass ich zuallererst den Spargel schälen werde.
Ah, vorab kann ich euch noch 2 Tipps geben, wie ihr frischen Spargel erkennt.
Da gibt's nämlich 2 Tipps, falls ihr die noch nicht kanntet.
Ich nehme jetzt hier schon mal ein abgebrochenes.
Wenn ihr euren Spargel *Spargel knackt* mit so einem Knack abbrechen könnt,
dann ist das ein Indiz dafür, dass er frisch ist.
Und dann gibt's noch einmal den Geräuschtest.
Da macht ihr dann einfach Musik *Spargel quietscht*
und wenn's dann so quietscht, dann ist der Spargel frisch.
Also probiert's gerne mal aus.
Ich werde jetzt hier zuallererst den Spargel schälen.
Da müsst ihr nicht ganz vorne an den Kopf. Der kann so bleiben, wie er ist.
Wir wollen diese Fasern - Also das, was so ein unangenehmes Mundgefühl macht -
das wollen wir hier erst mal komplett runternehmen.
Und auch ganz vorsichtig damit er eben nicht bricht, ich hatte nämlich gerade schon das Problem.
So, jetzt noch dieses holzige Ende einmal abschneiden.
So, mein Spargel ist vorbereitet.
Hier habe ich einen großen Topf mit Wasser, das habe ich einmal zum Kochen gebracht.
Und jetzt geben wir nicht nur Salz dazu, sondern auch ganz wichtig: Zucker.
Das bewirkt, dass einfach diese Bitterstoffe nochmal ausgeglichen bzw. entzogen werden.
Daher ist Zucker sehr, sehr wichtig.
Jetzt einfach reingeben und gar kochen lassen. Je nach Dicke dauert das so 8-12min.
So, jetzt ist alles fertig.
Der Spargel ist gar, die Kartoffeln sind fertig, die Sauce Hollandaise sowieso
und jetzt müssen wir einfach nur noch anrichten.
Ich nehme sie jetzt hier vorsichtig einmal raus... ein bisschen abtropfen lassen.
Und ich mach's so, dass ich's nochmal hier auf Küchenpapier lege weil ich mag's dann nicht ganz so wässrig.
Das ist so richtige, richtige Hausmannskost heute. Muss auch mal sein!
Und wenn ihr noch mehr Wünsche habt bezüglich Rezepten, die so klassisch sind,
wo ihr gern noch ein paar Tipps und Tricks möchtet, dann schreibt mir das gerne jetzt unten in die Kommentare.
Denn ich lese mir alle Kommentare durch und ich richte mich immer sehr nach euren Wünschen.
Übrigens mache ich's jetzt so, dass zum Sud - also zu diesem Spargelsud
jetzt noch der Rest reinkommt.
Dann lasse ich das auch nochmal ein paar Minuten köcheln und mache daraus dann eine richtig schöne Suppe.
So, und jetzt einfach anrichten. Hamza, wir teilen uns einen Teller, oder?
Das kommt jetzt alles auf einen Teller. Weil eigentlich ist das für 2 Personen aber ich möcht's jetzt schick anrichten
und dann sieht's schöner aus, wenn's ein bisschen voller ist.
Mein innerer Monk, der sagt mir: "Mach alle Köpfe in eine Richtung!"
Die Sauce Hollandaise einmal oben drauf geben..
So, da kommen jetzt noch die Kartoffeln dazu
und dann gebe ich noch ein bisschen Petersilie obendrauf, einfach für die Optik.
Und dann ist es fertig!
Macht's unbedingt nach und schreibt mir dann in die Kommentare wie's euch geschmeckt hat.
So, und jetzt nehmt ihr euch von der Kartoffel, vom Spargel und ganz viel von der Sauce Hollandaise
und lasst es euch noch richtig schön warm schmecken.
Guten Hunger!
Sehr lecker!
Macht's unbedingt nach, schreibt mir in die Kommentare wie's euch geschmeckt hat
und hinterlasst meinem Kanal ein kostenloses Abo wenn euch das Video gefallen hat.
Und dann würde ich einfach mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!